[Musique]
paulo tiens moi à la balle aussi vite
que tu peux si tu bois assez tu sentiras
rien de quoi est-ce que tu parles je
vais pas sentir quoi monsieur getty
votre petit fils il se fait kidnapper
je dis aux personnes qui vont enlever je
vous implore de libérer mon fils c'est
un bon docteur je te promets pas oui 17
millions da pour le relâcher n'hésitez
d'argent mois alors demandez votre
beau-père il a tout l'argent du monde
tout un prix de vente enlever une petit
quelque chose de vraie difficulté dans
ma vie de réussir à définir le prix
correct
sfr et du vivre
il faut payer la rançon
vont faire à paul des choses qui rêvait
diable si on ne donne pas ce qu'ils
demandent
[Musique]
combien êtes vous prêt à payer pour
votre petit fils si ce n'est pas 10 7
millions dit oui jo
17 millions ça rameute les foules
oui
[Musique]
vol et sa mère avait tout manigancé ce
que paul vous a dit qu'il voulait se
faire tirer
quel côté êtes-vous monsieur chase puis
cru pouvoir confiance au mali
[Musique]
faut payer ou lui a réservé un billet
une oreille
je ne vais rien faire
aux personnes jamais été aussi riche que
vous ne l'êtes en ce moment je refuse de
perdre mon argent combien vous faut-il
pour vous sentir en sécurité plus
[Musique]
fait envie